[Music]
design hate kids
it's hard to explain okay
my friends the bitterness of expectation
not met and concurrent fear of things
that you don't know hate something you
almost feel it more it's more than just
an intense dislike hate
yes I hated bra disgusting hurtful
destructive anymore words I've got more
anger
I think hatred is sort of
hmm I think injured is not having any
sympathy or empathy for any particular
Zing's existence whether is that be a
person or an object or really anything
something you just like really strongly
someone or something or some concept or
anything you dislike really problem it
comes with themselves this is the first
they wake up the hatred that will take
right then to make the other person icon
anything then but if you don't
participate you ain't got egg what's up
man we want to sort there's all gonna be
hidden oasis how you are you react
defining hate it's a lack of Jesus in
your life hate is just
something made of honestly hatred is
a product of belief I guess I believe
you know without separate beliefs no one
would hate each other okay we just all
people I would define it as tolerance a
lack of understanding and a lack of
desire to be understanding i define hate
as a Donald Trump what's been going on
this past weekend the Charleston drama -
fine hey stupid in one word or sentence
where do you want to put in Donald Trump
hey right there misconceptions who push
someone who think I'll never different
from what they are I would define it as
like something ugly I don't know what
else to say hey-ya discriminating
someone is something that people feel
for anything pretty much or somewhat a
bad feeling that energy
a tough question we go like you can hate
towards people you hate to it like
difference being Larry something he
wants more like as something that I mean
argument you and should be hate would be
you have more contention it's your
everything but settled it's not happy
and joyful and fearful opposite of us
Hey
I hate going it's really good answer no
no like a really strong emotion I guess
the unbridled dislike for others that
has no reason other than emotions and
you think that's negative I'm assuming
now but I think that you're you're
trying to put something together and I
jump it will give us an answer for what
we're seeing in the world right now
because I don't like passionate
distortion of my spirit based on
something that's going on in the world
and I have no problem answering a
question that you are having an
interaction somebody I have no clue who
you are what you're about but you're
still a person there's that respect and
I think that's more of a definition of
the law for my fellow human being and
whatever we're experiencing in the world
today it's it's disappointing but we'll
get we'll get better I think we'll get
better
just a little interactions like this I
think so too
what's your name Sariah there i am dave
yeah you to really be I hope I hope you
have some good responses
[Music]